time travel has not yet been invented
but 30 years from now and will have been
Joe player who plays a younger version
works for a mob in the future I'm one of
many specialized assassins in our
present called loopers and this mob gets
rid of people by zapping them back 30
years where Joe kills them and gets rid
of the bodies he's like a hitman so in
criminal organizations in the future
needs someone God is happening back to
me
and I eliminate the target from the
future and then one day he shows up for
work and his the person who's supposed
to kill appears in front of him and it's
his older self it's Bruce and he can't
pull the trigger and he lets himself
around at some point they have a scene
together where they kind of finally
meets and there's this long dialogue
scene between the two of them it's it's
it's really fun because Joe is is doing
kind of a Bruce impression he also has
all this makeup to look like a young
Bruce Willis it's a really interesting
transformation the future time travel is
outlawed used only in secret by the
largest criminal organization I travels
a really weird thing in in narratives
because it's so easy for it to
completely take over the narrative in
four suddenly all you're doing is
thinking about butterflies and paradoxes
and grandfather also wrote the film and
I tried to figure out how to circumvent
that and how to keep it about the story
and the characters so time travel sets
up this situation but then hopefully
gets out of the way a little bit so that
your your brain isn't fried
and you can kind of enjoy the ride this
time travel crap was fries your brain
like an egg sci fi is I mean just been
my favorite genre since I was like it's
kind of the genre I feel like we all
grew up loving Star Wars The Blade
Runner it's aliens kind of feel like the
genre in movies as our generation was
growing up the sophisticated special
effects were kind of coming into a new
phase starting with Star Wars and had it
grew up with us and so it's something
that's really comfortable it's also a
pool of genre because it's a genre that
it's kind of nothing it just sci-fi on
its own is not really a definable thing
it's something that has two combined
with another genre so you know with the
blade runner a sci-fi noir you know
orale and a sci-fi monster movie it's
really this kind of chief that slips
over something else and to me I love
messing around with genre and mixing
them up and matching of it so it's
something that really appeals to me it
lets you play with some pretty cool toys
and concepts and ideas
music the way we did it was really fun
we I mean it's it's a big action movie
but we but it's kind of like a left turn
from that we didn't want to go down the
road of like a traditional big action
score so what we did is I actually came
down to New Orleans and I was there for
the whole time we were shooting the
movie and I brought a field recorder and
I just like basically wandered around
the city for a month like gathering
sounds like industrial fans and
treadmills in my hotel room and engines
stuff from the set and then um and then
I worked with a team to like basically
take these sounds from the world and
turn them into playable instruments so
it kind of has this like this slightly
recognizable thing but it strikes you
really differently and and all of these
like cycling rhythms became both like
tonal instruments but also percussive
instruments that we've been kind of
built this sort of like this soundscape
for the world from